my makeshift glove pretty it's pretty
lackluster and I'm missing a stone but
hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamra just saw and Tamra
just saw Avengers endgame this is gonna
be a no spoiler reaction video
no spoilers to be had if you would have
told me with little baby Tamra walked
her ass in to see Iron Man 1 then it
would eventually lead to this film I
would have cried just as much as I cried
during endgame I had the single best
theatre experience that I've ever had
watching a movie in in a theatre again
theater experience I felt surrounded by
people who were just as invested in this
as me I had their posted something
really great on Twitter about how we're
all different level of fan and that just
that doesn't mean that we can't all
enjoy it and I felt that in the theater
there was just so many people just show
pumped out of their minds excited to see
this and it oh my god the energy was
amazing I full-volume yelled yes like 10
times and I was surrounded by people
screaming and laughing throughout and
like just sobbing sobbing at the end to
just you hear these broken people
brokenly sobbing in the back and it was
amazing
since it sounded weird it was so great
how people were sad this movie is three
hours I don't know if you know anything
about my movie going experience but I
tend to not enjoy very very long movies
and this was not that I felt like it was
an hour and a half
at one point the guy next to me reached
over to his son and was like it's
already been an hour and a half we said
we were halfway through and it felt like
it had been 20 minutes it was so easy to
watch so entertaining throughout there's
you know act 1 act 2 x3 are vastly
different from each other and I think
they they build so well to get to act 3
and it feels so deserved I can't imagine
that anyone's going to be too upset with
the pacing of this movie if they're
going and wanting to enjoy it sure
because I don't like superhero films you
probably don't want to sit through a
three-hour one that has a lot of inside
jokes like inside information so yeah
sure probably not but if you're somebody
who has been watching these films or
just loves them in general but
specifically if you've been watching
these films since Ironman one and you
watch them all and and you're waiting
for this resounding end game then I
can't imagine you're not going to just
feel pure joy you know I was filled with
joy the whole time I posted on Twitter
that I had seen it and that I had
thought that it was at least impactful I
don't know that I really evoke Tenny
emotion of positivity or negativity but
I loved it and I got a lot of people
responding that they didn't know how to
feel about it or that they didn't love
it
that's like story of my movie-going life
I tend to love big epics like this
especially in the superhero or like
sci-fi Star Wars kind of realms I just
really enjoy them it seems like this
amazing feat that they had done this you
get some incredible scenes specifically
the end holy and the emotion that is
brought out in this frickin film is
insanity crazy
in saying that we feel these strong
emotions about superheroes who God you
know in the 90 like it just I just keep
thinking back to the past of superhero
movies and what Marvel has done and DC
but was in this instance what Marvel has
done for superhero films and nerd
culture and it's so exciting and so you
feel the weight of that when you're
watching it and it's just uh I was
smiling and crying throughout again
there's a little boy sitting next to me
and he kept looking at me
I think genuinely worried that this
adult woman was sobbing so much and it
wasn't sad sobbing either some of it
sure but it mostly it was just I'm just
so happy to be watching this did you
awesome things with time travel
they'll probably not I would say that's
the one moment in the movie where the
time travel really doesn't link up at
all like it doesn't really make sense to
me I have to see this 17 more times
literally it's it ended and I was like I
wouldn't I would legit sit through this
again right now it was just so good but
the time travel kind of didn't make that
much sense and I think the only reason
why it's so doubt to me is because they
made a joke about it in the film they
were like well it's not gonna be like
you know the movies where they get it
wrong and they list some movies and that
I I knew the reference to because of
chambers ever seen you ever just I think
you thank you and then they went off of
them they did those things that kind of
stuck out after watching infinity Wars I
knew that what I was going into this
that I would be expecting that was a
weird sentence that I just said I'm very
excited I knew going into this at
because of infinity war and because of
contracts ending I I wanted to this
thinking that I knew who was going to
make it out and who was not going to
make it out and I was pleasantly
surprised and and you know not
pleasantly surprised sad but it made
sense you get a resolution at the end
that feels right and still leaves things
open for the
future but it feels like the end of an
era
it feels like everything they've been
working towards from Iron Man 1 up until
now has a resolution I'm gonna cry just
thinking about it it's so much fun to
just go in and sit back and revel in
this amazing thing that they've done
it's so much fun I loved it I loved it
20 seconds in there's a joke about
putting ketchup on hotdogs that went
over smashingly in my theater the thing
in Chicago not supposed to put ketchup
on your hot dogs they get really mad
about it I wrote somber opening I would
say the first 2/3 is pretty damn well
now the whole movies pretty somber and
then you get just juicy beautiful
emotion throughout and incredible
character work and just building of
characters and you see people you
haven't seen in a long time there's
flashes of incredible action the third
act has some of the best action I've
ever seen in in movie history ever done
signed sealed delivered I'm yours
amazing it's a long sad movie for sure
but I left not having taken that from it
I know with it in theory I know and in
practice it is it's a long sad movie but
I left not having gotten a long sad
movie from and I left having gotten so
so much more and I think that's because
they did they deserve to take the time
they took in the sad moments and in the
lingering parts I wrote an emotional
chasm it's the third note that I wrote
and I have pages of notes so that's
emotional this movie is I wrote Captain
Marvel is so much cooler in this movie
and I liked Captain Marvel send your
hate now let it flooded I feed off of it
not really I don't but I enjoyed Captain
Marvel and I thought she was way better
utilized in this she wasn't used that
much but when I go back and think about
it only the core group really was a
nebula who I loved there
characters who didn't get a ton of
screen time and she was one of those but
she has one of the best scenes in the
film the hands down just the coolest and
I think some of her quick quips there's
one too spider-man and and I have really
enjoyed her in this film a lot I wrote
that
I'm weirdly and wildly attracted to the
Hulk in this movie sorry about it I
can't I can't help it but I am and that
that's just where we're at and we're
gonna move on from it
okay this might be a spoiler but it's
not like a crucial spoiler but Thor has
gained some weight since all of that
shenanigan went down infinitely more and
I just wrote fat Thor is so relatable
people you see people just mad sprinting
to the bathroom to pee and like mad
sprinting back so you don't miss
anything I read this article before
going in about what time to go to the
bathroom I type with diabetic I drink a
lot of fluids I'm gonna have to pee I
get P anxiety I'm gonna have to pee
after Peters talking about peeing right
now P I found it the best time to go
which is because that's when I went and
I found out for my brother that I miss
absolutely nothing was when they meet
Hulk to have lunch so if you haven't
seen it you're going to see it it's in
the first half so I didn't even really
have to go that bad but I was like I
definitely will at the end and I do not
want to miss anything then so when hope
goes to lunch there there you go do it
then literally you won't miss anything
we got a cameo from someone that I did
not think we would ever see in a Marvel
film again again a lot of cameos from
people that I wasn't expecting that were
just blessed surprises it made me want
to rewatch a lot of these origin stories
again I need to watch Captain America
again he was such a insane delight in
this film he accounted for like six of
my scream yeses and also when I say it
everyone was excited and clapping and
yelling it wasn't just me yelling yes I
promise
Captain America was oh so good an
emotional and powerful and badass and
funny in times I
oh oh oh
Hulk is hot I had to write a choice I
just wrote I orgasm two seven times
not literally but figuratively you're
incredible Captain America moment insane
fight absolute unit best theater
experience I've ever had also best
Marvel film I've ever seen
did I just say that it came out of my
mouth and I think it's true best Marvel
film there's a girl gang moment that's
just doesn't make a lot of sense no but
I loved it it was awesome it was awesome
just let me have it
part of the journey is the end I just I
can't believe it so good man I think I'm
gonna go see it again today I just can't
stop thinking about it I didn't go to
sleep until like 5:00 a.m. last night
because I could not stop thinking about
it it's pretty telling to my character
that I can't sit through part 1 & 2
because they're through yeah you're slug
but this I was like wow
felt like 10 minutes amazing Bravo
so take that with a grain of salt also
as you will thank you so much for
watching I had the best time with this
it was absolutely a delight emotional
funny impactful heavy I will see you all
next week with something vastly less
interesting I'm sure because this was
lit bye bye also I'm gonna be posting a
spoiler filled review on my patriotic
you're interested in that yeah by that
is America's ass